big bushy tail and pull it let's do that  the scenes where spacer interacts with  other props  so we're actually creating a practical  version so that they can cut from their  cg beta into our practical beta and then  have it wriggling around  looks good right we also have scenes  with owen where owen carries visa in a  sling so that interaction really  requires a practical puppet as opposed  to a cg one is that a dinosaur on your  shoulder  yeah  what it was a lot of fun to be able to  do that this thing is basically a very  very expensive puppet wearing  another very very expensive puppet  we have what we call a performance  puppet a much more lightweight version  it'll have eyes in but you can see here  it's it's posable so we can pose the  arms and it's going to be a lot lighter  than the animatronic because it hasn't  got a robot inside so effectively  someone can take these handles and  actually perform it on the day  you